Empleado público
guarda este reel que te puede interesar,
¿cuánto se le debe incrementar
en el salario a los empleos públicos para 2024?
Si no lo sabes, quédate que aquí te lo cuento.
El Presidente de la República
por medio de un decreto
expide cuál es el tope máximo para incrementar
los salarios de los empleos públicos.
Normalmente lo hace entre junio y julio de cada año
y este será retroactivo al uno de enero del 2 024
y posteriormente este decreto
la entidad pública tiene que expedir
otro acto administrativo
donde le dice cuál es el valor
o porcentaje exacto que se le debe incrementar
al empleado público
y este empleado público
tendrá derecho a unos salarios y prestaciones sociales
retroactivas
contadas a partir del uno de enero del 2 024.
Ahora bien,
el Presidente de la república no se demora mucho
en realizar o expedir ese decreto.
¿Tú qué piensas?